the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
if you look at syllabus I have my office
hour Monday 5:00 to 6:00
and I would like to I know many of you
but also I many of you I do not know if
we have not met before I would like to
ask you come to my office hour and let's
chat a little bit and see what's your
interest that way I can better prepare
myself I also read through your feedback
in the first class as I expected that
they interest the various broadly and
also the background where is broadly
that's always the nature I encounter in
the past we don't have a good solution
for that so I ask if you have learned
stuff be patient if you haven't we'll
come over there get together and many of
you also are very much interested in
liquid so I want to tell you that liquid
it's very difficult ok and when I wrote
the book I put everything on a parallel
paths I can deal with solid crystal
solid crystalline solid and gas photons
electrons but when it came to liquid it
become a lot more complicated so if you
look at the book there was a specific
chapter on liquid and that you have to
be more patient and wait until almost
the end of this class ok with that
remember I would like to see you if we
have
talk people come to my office hour and
let's know each other better if you
think about what we talked in the last
lecture last time we reviewed the
classical laws this for heat for
momentum right heat conduction heat
conversion thermal radiation in terms of
momentum for example they lived in
shirts retinol and we are also almost
all mass diffusion ficks law so those
are they constitute relations for the
transport processes so we the classical
laws and I did also we went into more
microscopic picture behind this
classical laws and we say at the end in
terms of carriers for energy momentum
charge
I say we only have essentially four
types major types molecules electrons
photons and lattice vibration I broader
than up the name for lumps right so we
went to some microscopic description for
those transport processes and what I
simply file this problem is a gas
picture I have molecular gas in a box
I have electron gas in a box and the
photon gas in box so that's why we can
do a parallel treatment for all those
energy carriers and what I am going to
do in today's lecture
it's trying to give a first crack on the
questions that we're going to answer
through the whole semester and those
questions what are the question ones are
us I want to ask now if I look at this
macro scopic picture I want to take
first a wine individual carrier and ask
what's its energy I can also ask you
what's a momentum charge but let me just
take the energy first and then I'm going
to look at a cluster a box of those
carriers molecules a certain temperature
I asked how many of those carriers have
certain energy and how far how fast they
travel so first question is how much
okay here you can see how much energy
but there's one carrier right and then
I'm going to ask how many of them and
how fast they travel and how far they
travel and how do you interact
okay and with that we can start I give
you a simple derivation of the diffusion
laws last time we showed Ohm's law for
example this time I will show you the
free or heat conduction law and with
that you can go back and do other laws
the ficks law and Newton's shear stress
no this can all be similarly done so
let's look at per energy of pre carrier
right so we can say how much look at the
one carrier so I have a box of four gas
molecules let's say I have a hydrogen
and this is a diatomic molecule right so
we have two hydrogen atoms and we'll
have one hydrogen and another hydrogen
atom they are bound together and then
when I look at ER the energy of this
molecule I look how the possible modes
possible ways of restoring energy by the
molecule what are the forms of energy
I'm sorry okay so we have kinetic energy
that's a translation so this hydrogen
molecule is the movement wrong right and
in that case I look at the mass Center I
can say okay I don't care about this two
individual atoms there they are just a
cluster and the mobile I certain
velocity and the kinetic energy e equals
one-half MV squared right so last time I
made a statement if you understand
energy momentum and entropy and now we
look and go into the molecular picture
and look at those energy so this is a
translation kinetic energy without our
energies rotation vibration okay and
let's look at the vibration so this two
molecules are bound by spring we in fact
talked about the the inter-atomic force
in the last lecture right they a minimum
point is the equilibrium so we can
approximate as a sprint and this is a
relative vibration within these two
atoms that's another way to store the
energy right so the vibration
and in fact that you can simplify this
because this now is the to add emotion
but if you simplify treta to the center
of the mass and you can essentially do a
effective mad sprint problem so this is
a classic ER math sprint problem and
then you know for this classic ER spread
mass what's the energy energy let's say
you have the displacement that is X okay
FK x squared that's the potential
there's another part right one
translation also MV square this is a way
not the center of mass moving it's a
relative vibration so the mass is
relative to the center this is the
potential energy KX squared right uh
yeah I'm not considering gravity you can
add a gravitation yeah that's that's a
that that's possible okay so we have our
vibration and you also mention rotation
so we have also rotation and rotation is
now I can take a simple picture I fix
this sprint right and now I have a rod
with two balls attached to it and they
will rotate and the energy our
rotational energy is a one-half I Omega
squared right I is the moment of inertia
and the Omega square is only is the
angular momentum the angular velocity
right
so we have translation vibration
rotation anything else anything
don't forget the charge right so if I
look at individual hydrogen atom and it
has nuclear and has electrons more wrong
okay so we also have electronic and the
electronic energy I can rather either
use Yi simple or potential the
interaction of two charge let's say here
is the Q one here is the Q 2 then the
Coulomb potential right the Coulomb
interaction two charges anyone remember
that Q 1 Q 2 4 PI epsilon R each one is
dielectric constant right R is the
separation between the two okay so those
are the form of energy this molecule
stores with it so when we think about
internal energy of a gas they are stored
in those forms translation vibration
rotation electronic okay and so that's
the the case of a molecule and if we go
to solid which is a lot more complex
we'll talk more later let's see last
time we gave a simple picture of
connecting the atom by Sprint so it has
a vibration right and also each atom has
electrons and lukla so it has the
electronic
and in fact for solid it doesn't have
this rotation right the atoms don't
rotate it's fixed there so that's the in
essence that's better
right when I deal with the liquid I have
more trouble because of all this other
possibilities
okay so let's leave this to later and
what I want to see is those are all the
classic reformed classic expressions
right and the word we are going to move
on next is to give the quantizer form in
quantum mechanics right what are the
micro the energy of the translation
vibration rotation and electronic and
there we'll see the quantization of
energy levels and that's very important
okay now this is a individual energy how
much what we look like is how many of
them okay and I have a box of molecule
here and of course I can say for per
unit volume this is the lamber of
molecules per unit volume right that's
the number of molecule in our volume but
each molecule could have 1/2 MV squared
that way in my current picture is not
defined velocity right
could be anywhere from negative infinity
the vector negative infinity to positive
infinity so the question is if I give
you a box of gas a certain temperature T
now I bring the thermal pot how much
energy what's the probability of the
molecule have it has certain value of
energy e right because the lumber of
molecules is very large I have to bring
in this statistical picture okay so I
temperature T temperature T let's look
at the translation only so I can simply
find my picture even a more simplified I
don't consider a hydrogen atom I
consider a he new madam right monatomic
gas translation energy Oh me of course
there your I chronic apart so I
temperature T how much is say what's the
probability alpha molecule has actually
certain value of energy right what's the
answer
I
yeah so that's the this is going to the
statistic where are some of physics
statistical physics and the distribution
is given by the famous Boardman factor I
try to use what captors know so boards
my factor tells you the probability of
funding of a molecule atom has certain
energy E I temperature T is a
localization this is a probability right
so it has a localization constant minus
the e over KB T and this KB is the
Boltzmann constant we mentioned last
time KB is a one point three eight ten
to the minus twenty-three char per
Kelvin right so that's the portsmen
factor and some of you taking
statistical physics and that's easy if
you haven't taken it you learned a
reading slow anytime people look like
that the temperature dependent they
always like to put the exponential
factor that's because the burbs minds
behind it okay and it will come back to
this later on so I'm going to build on
this exponential factor and to determine
what's the average energy per molecule
translational energy per molecule and I
do it first I need to find this
normalization factor a and I determine
this probability
so let's exam the translation
energy and way square so way is really
had this vector right 3x we buy visas
are right way X square plus V Y square
plus V Z square
ok and now I take advantage of the
definition flow this F probability is I
find the molecule having velocity from
minus infinity to plus infinity law
relates to what right that's what the
Renji can have so from the normalization
from malice influenza plus infinite for
V X V Y VZ right I'm doing it first I'll
do it in Cartesian coordinate then I'll
transfer to a spherical coordinate so
let's look at the first Cartesian
coordinate from malice infinite to plus
infinite DV X minus infinity to plus
infinity
DV Y and one warning is that you will
often encounter many of those integral
forms because we when we look at the
probability we have to integrate from
all the possible states so we actually
very busy and F so I put a board to
manufacture so this is a integrand is a
I'm not going to be lazy I'm not writing
that exponent sure et so you put it in
there let's show you equal to 1 right
you look at it if you plug in your e in
the X square Y by square by Z square and
you can factor it out and you can do
your integration for giving X
individually TV by individual division
individually and with that you only have
a constant a you
nah no and you determine that constantly
right so I'm not going through the
indigo and you can either check the
integration table or there is a nice
mathematical trick if you like it to
play you can find that integral
integration value so here what I have is
a 2pi kb t three-halves
three-halves is because each of this
contribute 1/2 ok so now i have if i
plug in this a into the f i get f in
terms of weight X V Y V Z the
distribution I temperature T is M 2 pi K
BT 3 halves X pole ensure I want to
write the whole thing so this is the way
x squared plus 3y squared plus VZ square
divided by 2 KB T and this is the
Maxwell distribution Maxwell velocity
distribution distribution okay
so it looks pretty tedious about your
sensitivities of 1/2 way it's an energy
expression 1/2 MV squared
Maxwell what do you heard about Maxwell
what other things you heard about
Maxwell Maxwell equations right you
probably heard that rather than this
let's say in fact that you look at all
those very famous people in the ASAE
1800 1900 dip down many things right
Newton not just the Newton mechanics law
Newton optics also you can do all ok
here is velocity I'm using V X V Y V Z
right I could make my life much easier
if I use very often when I do this
integration I change the coordinate
rather than DV X DV by d VJ I do a
spherical coordinate because of symmetry
ok so if I change my coordinate to from
a DV X DV y DV Z into a spherical
coordinate due to symmetry is 4pi
squared DV right way now is they are the
radius and so the range of ways from 0
to positive infinity give infinite to
infinite right when you do if you think
about from DX dy DZ into our coordinate
ok so because of that and then my into
my normalization when I do localization
if I use firaga coordinate is 0 to
infinite and F way now I do not use the
V X V Y VZ I use F way and DV equals 1
that's another way to do it ok in this
case
your F way equals 4 pi way square M 2 pi
K BT 3 half exponential minus MV square
over 2 K BT it's simple rewriting the
Cartesian into a spherical but the point
I want to make is if you use a way you
you do not do see because the 4 PI Y
squared is already included here so you
can substitute this back into here and
just do your V X V Y VZ again let's be
consistent on which coordinate system
you will be using ok so what does this
tells me this math right I'm jumping
into a little mess because F is a
probability right so now with the
probability I can calculate the average
I can calculate what's the average
energy per molecule what's the average
any other numbers that you will be
interested so if I calculate the average
e per molecule the translation right so
my average will be now depend on which
system I choose you can do Cartesian or
you can do the spherical now I'm going
to write simply as a spherical so there
will two infinite and the energy is
one-half MV square that's the average e
quantity the quantity I want to find
what's the average given my f
distribution right so I times the F way
I integrated over way
now you can do your math to find that
the integral okay that's why I'm a water
you don't want to if you use a way you
want be consistent alway you don't do we
actually yvz
if you do we expedite way they start
from here you do your car teaching at
the beginning that F is different from
what I write here it's the same thing
but just be consistency so again I see
you can go do that homework and what you
have here is a 1/3 KBT or that match
give you a very beautiful very simple
result so KBT is a quantity you will see
often if you go to microscopic award
that's the thermal energy averages the
summer energy translational energy of
the molecule okay yes
if you divide by this that's one right
so that's I already
that's why myeloma lies Asian factor
right we're doing the normalization
factor okay so with this I can go to say
what's the average velocity I say how
right how much it here is a how much
your average energy per particle let's
see if based on this because of this
translation around 1/2 MV squared
so what's the average speed of the
molecule so we can go to calculate it
right so I have average of one half M V
squared equals 2/3 KBT and v square I
take a square root of that so I can tell
the magnitude is a here I have 3 KBT
over m ok what's the order magnitude
let's put in numbers I will always like
to put in Lumbridge I take a helium gas
and helium I can count how many what's
the mass right helium has two neutrons
to protons two electron masses to light
the electron masses or mm one one over
two thousands of the mass of protons I
forget about the electron mass right so
is a four times proton mass proton mass
one plate of six seven ten to the mass
31 kilo
you only remember SI unit not 31 I'm
sorry that's 30 why is the electron
twenty-seven
okay so if I plug in this mess KBT is
one point three eight ten to the minus
twenty three temperature 300 Kelvin
right so what I'll get is a average
velocity feed this one is one point 3 6
10 to the third meter per second it's
1,000 meter per second
yes ah
you could go to cockily right
you can you can calculate a it's also
KBT is the way my way square do that
you'll get also KBT that's the verge
okay so this is a he knew now if you put
the air air air average mass 27 right so
you put in 27 you'll get about 500
meters per second those molecules are
moving pretty fast and the last lecture
we discussed the momentum the pressure
right we're filling one atoms air
pressure and that's the momentum from
these fast-moving molecules right so ah
one more common and this is a
three-halves KBT there is a very
fundamental theorem behind this and that
is if the distribution obeys the boards
month distribution and at a high
temperature so by doing that high
temperature I can do the integration
later on when we introduce quantum you
can do the integration anymore okay
so at high temperature
the energy very close so I can do it
integration and if the energy form for
each energy form if it's a quadratic so
what do I mean
so if you look at the kinetic energy
this is a one-half MV x squared right
so each quadratic form if you go to do
the average energy you find that average
energy is 1/2 KT okay so 1/2 KT 1/2 KT
one concave KT that's rehab KT and
that's called the equipartition theorem
okay I give that's an example of the
translational energy and if you go to
vibration you see here right it's a
quadratic term one one-half KX squared
the velocity one-half MV square so at a
very high temperature this is 1/2 KT
average is speaking this is 1/2 KT and
the rotation one-half I Omega square
again it's quadratic right at a high
temperature that's 1/2 KT and in fact
the rotation that high temperature is
only 80 Kelvin or so for molecules the
vibration is go to a few thousand degree
okay so that's why you learn the ideal
gas law before right cv for different
monatomic ideal gas diatomic ideal gas
they have different civil use that's
because diatomic gas you have the
rotational modes coming in
and monotonic only the translation
that's the equal partition theorem well
we'll go to discuss that more later on
but here with that we get a feeling how
fast how much energy they have right
next what we want to answer is how far
they travel okay so we have
how far they travel by how far I mean
think about the air molecules in this
room right we have huge number always I
give Lambert the tendril 20 sir one more
right huge number of molecules and they
will collide with each other right so
long way they carry their energy and
then the next time they collide with the
other molecule so I want to give a very
quick estimation what's the distance
between those collision how far they
travel and so to do that let's say in
this case I have to think about the
molecule or longer a point right I have
to think about the final size of the
molecule this final size if you think
what determining size it could be the
electrical field potential right you
have a look Li and there say you like to
feel the spill out and then when the two
molecule collided with each other and
that's when they feel starter interact
okay and so I give a let's say a
diameter of a molecule as D okay this
diameter could be typically a few
angstroms one on strong to answer okay
and now if I think about this molecule
final size is a moving and that the
collision happens when there is another
molecule within distance of D right so
this is a 2d okay and the way I can
think about it do a very quick
estimation is let's say I have a
molecule and the over a trajectory say a
tube of diameter 2d you travel a certain
distance so this tool is the diameter 2d
right and travel certain distance let's
say here this distance is an L and that
what's the volume so that to the are the
area times distance right so the volume
is okay for pi 2 d square right this is
the area times the length gives me the
volume that this molecule does tube
sweeps right now how I decide the
average distance between one collision
one collision right that is when the
Lambert density per unit volume this is
the number of molecule per unit volume
times the volume when that equals one
that's one collision do you agree so
when the average number of for say the
per unit water and what's the number of
molecule x over this tube of 2d the
length L when this equals one that's a
one collision
this molecule will have with other
molecules and under this one condition
that L is really what I call the mean
free path so the average distance
between collision equals here you can
say is PI d square over N times n right
this is the mean free path that the
molecule travels between collision okay
and if you do a better job this one is
assuming the outer molecule do not move
right just a station or they distribute
there and if you do all the more detail
it turns out this expression is still
pretty good so the mean free path mean
free path is a more accurate I look for
the square root of 2 here is PI d square
times n okay now with that we can go to
guest estimate the mean free path cell
for the air molecules or typical gas so
if it's a gas ideal gas if the ideal gas
and we know pressure we derived last
time in fact is n this ism KBT right n
is the number of polygons per unit
volume not a more fraction right so this
is number of particle per unit volume so
I replace this n and in this case what I
gather the mean free path is KBT
square root of the tool PI d square
pressure okay
so let's put in lumber and see what's
the mean free path in a tubular
condition gamma is KBT is a KB is one
point three eight ten to the months
twenty three jar cowan times 300 Cowen
and square root of two pi D T let me
take a two point five on strong this is
by no means mean to be accurate meter
square okay pressure one atmosphere so
110 to the face right Newton per meter
square
and you go to putting all the lumber so
this is months twenty-third this is the
-20 right and here so that means to try
to minus twenty eight minus three and
here it's gentle face so minus 8 and
this 300 that you go to check your
numbers I give you a value I have this
one I get point one four so point 1 4
micron so 10 to the minus six 100
nanometer that's about the average
distance the air molecules travel in
this room okay
and if you recall before I said a disk
drive and the disc in my gravity is the
fuel nanometer now this separation and
the still using through mechanics to
design that slider so that they do not
light with the disc and you come to a
regime where the air molecule do not cry
with each other they'll collide with the
boundary more often right so this is the
average mean free path now you can see
in the case of ideal gas that pressure
is in the denominator how many of you do
vacuum related have vacuum experience
right so vacuum typical vacuum let's say
10 to the minus sixth all right you can
use a typical diffusion pump to easily
drive to 896 store so what's the
molecule mean free path when it's attend
to my sixth or I put in there 10 to the
minus sixth or is a 10 to the minus 6
remember here is a 10 to the fifth by
the 1 toy is 760 right one atmosphere is
760 Torr so this is the pressure you put
in there and you get 100 meter okay so
in vacuum pump vacuum system the
molecule do not collide with each each
other you use a evaporator
you heat it up you heat the atom the
atom go out that go straight to your
target so it's completely a ballistic
trajectory you don't do the heat
conduction diffusion theory anymore you
don't you have to trace the trajectory
right okay so this is a toughie
we have some idea and next let
briefly discuss how they interact with
each other
how do they interact okay
and I mentioned when the two molecules
right collided with each other it's
really the electric field extent certain
space and when the two molecule gets
close they like to feel collided as they
repel each other so they go different
trajectory right so you have simple you
can think about that too the larboard
coalition and if you want to do the
trajectory and they you what do you do
is during the collision you have energy
conservation you have momentum
conservation right so in that case this
is really the microscopic award the
basic conservation laws the conservation
principle you apply so you have energy
and momentum conservation and if the
collision is among the air molecules
it's a typically it's a limitedly how
faster they how far the molecule travels
so it's an internal you can sink it
either more as an internal stuff
internal loss but when you think about
the energy conversion what does a really
energy conversion mean energy conversion
is a one type of energy going to the
other type right so one gas molecule
drive a turbine is this kinetic energy
becomes today average
motion of the blade now another type is
think about the foot that would take
sale what's the energy conversion of
course or what do you want is that
photon you entry come out to get
electricity right but the water you
gather in the microscopic level is an
electron you sit over here a photon
comes in and leave the electron to here
you have the first step of your energy
conversion already right of course
that's neither your food will take CIA
yet and the light from the lamp is
absorbed by all the stuff around us you
entry that's the energy conversion
except at the end we can't capture it
right and so you have different losses
in the process that you have to take
care if you want to finally extract the
things that's useful okay so this kind
of interaction is dealing with the
coalition dealing with the interaction
this is arguably the most complicated
step in the transport okay now with that
ah let's go to what I want to give you
is a simple connecticut theory of
transport so I know there are see how
many how long air molecule will travel
and then what I'm what I'm going to do
next is to show how we can do a simple
derivation for the Fourier law of heat
conduction and as I said that you can do
the same derivation using this
in strategy for mass diffusion for
momentum this a transfer and in fact you
have homework on this so I'm considered
conduction only no no averaging motion
right I have the gas molecules and any
gas in fact applies to electron apply
the photon as long as I have this gas
picture right and I have a temperature
gradient in the X direction so this is a
P flow in the X direction right
temperature within that and I want to
derive the Fourier law and the
microscopically if I can count
basically I'm counting so when I look at
the flux right across certain cross
section so here I'm going to say this is
the cross section I'm looking at here is
the X on the Left I have molecules on
the right I have molecules right and the
molecules are doing random motion and on
the left there are slide higher
temperature on the right side lower
temperature now some of this molecule
will go across this imaginary interface
I draw without coalition so icon that
this molecule that can go through the
interface so from left to right months
from right to left that's my left flux
okay so I'm doing my energy balance and
so what I can't I say left I have here
within how I say I say what's the range
this is a the way x times tau how is the
time between coalition okay
that's sometimes forgot mentioned how
because I have a mean free pass so I
have the mean free path / velocity that
gives your speed gives me the average of
time between collisions right so I say
VX because this is velocity in the X
component in X direction we have X times
tau as long as those molecules is the
way in this range they can go across
this imagined interface here right and
of course only half of them have that
chance half goes this way you have to go
the other way I'm doing the random right
right Brownian motion so I have my Q is
1/2 this is the average number per unit
per unit volume and times the VX this is
the speed so if you look at this this
gives me here is a per unit volume here
are the meter per second so that gives
me per meter square per second that's
what it flux write the flux of the
particles per meter square per second
and times the each particle carry this
energy so you can replace that energy by
charge
that's a diffusion of charge right if
you do one that's the diffusion order if
you give you times the mass of a
particle that's the diffusion of mass in
terms of the weight right so here is X
months VX times tau that's on the Left
going to write and that mass from the
right going to left so there are also
half of this this is also VX over tau
that's the chance going from left to the
right so that's the difference of the
two gives me you see here they come it's
VX plus tau
right so that's my heat flux if you
check this is a 1 over meter square or
cubic here is a meter per second here is
jar so I will get a watt per meter
square okay and of course what I'm going
to do next all here is a V X X
components what I'm going to do Lex
laser to write it into differential form
this is a very short write as lines I'm
dealing with the macroscopic I can write
this 100 nanometer ranging into a
differential form so I do my
differential
what I have is a cure equals because
this is a positive is malice so I have -
in the front 1/2 D and way X tau R e
that's what's inside and D X and they
the exit difference is V X tau minus V X
tau so I have to be X tau right so now
I'm doing a little skip Ian I'm going to
put the V X pull the X out I neglect all
those temperature dependence of velocity
and this is actually because that you
can have capital mass and heat transfer
but I'm escaping making the sense easier
so what I have here is 1/2 console I
have a way x squared cow and D n times E
is yo and DX right yo is energy per unit
volume okay so VX square is a one-third
of Y square I'm doing right so what I
have here out the negative sign so I
have one third way square tau and do DT
I'm using chain rule DT DX what's this
do DT that's the heat yeah specific heat
per unit volume right so this one is say
is the specific here's jar meter cubic
Kelvin
typically we do specific for unit
density per unit mass but it's fine so
what I have here is a k4 elo dtdx and I
also obtain expression for K is a 1 sir
say way tau square right now CV squared
hub CV square tau and which is a 1/3 C
gamma way say V gamma so this is the
Fourier law and also the expression for
the thermal conductivity right ok and if
you look at thermal conductivity is
proportional to the mean free path
proportional velocity proportional
specific heat if you check for gas was
high which gas has a high thermal
conductivity in them so the velocity is
higher
okay and so we have with that I have the
simple derivation and later on we're
going to give you more complicated
derivation based on boards my equation
but this is a hand waving one and it's
pretty good at the end if you use the
board's mind you'll still get K equals 1
through 2 see V gamma ok any questions
here without if not let's make a few
comment
so those of course I want to learn the
classical diffusing theory right and you
can see immediately if I do take the
example of the disk drive my space is
much smaller than this mean free path I
cannot do that derivative anymore right
so I have to go to look at more
complicated so this is the where the
Nano start to deviate so what we're
looking when we're looking today what's
the fundamental difference right so I
have
and what's really the micro-nano
fundamental difference and there are
server regimes one is I always have a
device Chris Kuehl ends for example in
this slider the describe is the
separation between slider and disc right
so I have one is a high-risk length the
mean free pass if the mean free path
becomes larger or comparable to a
separation let's say D a critical length
of the transport problem right and in
that case the diffusion theory will no
longer be valid and the air molecule
will collide with the boundary and as
long as the quantum effects are not
important then you run into a classical
side effect regime so classical size
effect
so this is a one case right but you can
ask how do you know your condom size
defector is not important right so let's
take a look now we're going to move
little bit into condom and so the next
case is a quantum size effect and in
fact sometimes I don't like to call the
quantum size effect
I like a tall coid wavy effect right and
this is the case when you have to think
about the wavelengths as another
Christic things then skill and I will I
prefer to call this wavy effects I'm
sure that people don't always agree with
me but say ah here let's take a look
plus with the quantum with the wave
we'll take a basic picture here we know
we're going to get into more in the next
lecture that see anything from quantum
per picture is both wave and the
particle right so wave has a wavelength
and so we have a wavelength this is my
nom de right
and in the quantum picture against a
we're going more in the lecture lecture
the wavelength and the momentum is
related through the planck constant h
right HP is the Planck constant six
point six 10 to the minus 34 jar-jar
second okay so now when the waves waves
is actually important I'm going to give
a very simple argument example in fact I
say you will say that a significant
difference even though we in my both
most of my research is the fall into
classical size the effect regime but
I've been always thinking it's much
better if you started with the wave
picture to understand how the way we go
from wave to the particle why that's
because when you go nano there is always
the interface a interface idea interface
is zero sickness zero sicknesses compare
anything is too thin too small right so
there the way we affect always one can
start with the thing about the wave
reflection by the interface so even
though most of you probably don't deal
with waves very often I want to
emphasize the word spend a lot of time
talked about the waves so let me make a
simple argument of standing wave I have
a film all in the first lecture I say if
you go to a professor Mundi but when
this website you'll see he make
beautiful thoughts right nano sized dots
and so I simplify that as a film I make
a two-dimensional verson freestanding
film
I got a electron wave inside right I
have charge inside
I have Adam you can single either way so
this is a wave inside and there's a
boundary it cannot come out right so
what do you have there
so confine the boundary simplest picture
is clamped right you see okay my wave
you I thought I depends
I wasn't sure when coming to this stage
so I didn't bring the violin I have okay
it's a standing wave right so let's
start with standing we picture and I
have a finite thickness okay let me say
my simplest picture is standing wave
with at the boundary is zero vibration I
clamp these two boundaries right so then
my wave form this is a the standing wave
the simplest one mode of standing wave
and the legs mode right so I have those
different modes of standing wave inside
and I can use the expression I gave and
this requirement to give you basic
quantization result so how we do it
lambda over two right that's the basic
length and here is 2 times lambda over
to say so it's just lambda and at times
the n this n is a integer no longer the
number density anymore
right so lambda works with times n
should equal to the thickness G or
diameter right order MACUL so this is d
and this gives me lambda equals to D
over n right and that will give me
momentum you are H over lambda and
that's a 2 and D H we will wait sorry
so 2 NH over no NH over 2 D right that's
a momentum
okay I know I say I come to kinetic
energy this is a I'm jumping here I say
ok this way will also has a momentum and
eyes the kinetic energy and this is a
fun ties the momentum because that n
must be integer and equals 1/2 right so
now the energy e and s if I do the
classic R is the MV square and I write
it into a momentum square 2 m at the
moment has the same way and put the
momentum again so I will get 8m d square
and the N square times H square so now
suddenly the energy of this particle is
discontinuous because of the wave
requirement right so I need to ask is
this important so that clearly depends
on what's the m and what's the end right
if the m and say what's the m and what's
d if m ID a large the energy separation
is very small if they are small this
becomes very important how important it
is
so we need to have again order magnitude
even though I always give you very very
small numbers but I want you to be
proficient in those numbers you can
choose whatever unit you use so let me
first give order magnitude of KBT right
we said everything is the equal
partition and a 1/2 KBT so KB T is a
good number to remember how large is KBT
KBT is one point three eight ten to the
minus twenty third jar kaolin and times
300 Kelvin and this gives me
let me do that by heart okay is a four
point one six ten to the months twenty
one jar
you see I don't remember this lumber the
probability reason is here I make a jump
most of time I like to remember in
electron volts okay if Y electron volt
is a one electron actually under one
volt
what's the energy so Y electron what's
the charge of electron in the 19 Coulomb
times the one volt so this is one point
six ten to the minus nineteen jar and if
you convert this KBT into a jar this is
26 milli electron volt that's what I
remember
oh thank you yeah I used to be able to
do bring calculations 26 milli electron
volts that's a room temperature okay
so why I do that let's nickel to look at
the year right I'm going to put the
electron into a film let's say the film
is a hundred unstrung ten nanometer okay
so one electron let's be consistent
electron in ten nanometer film what's
the mass of electron
9.1 10 to the minus thirty one kilogram
okay so you plug in the lumber here is
the line point one 10 to the minus
thirty one kilogram
here is a ten months because 110
nanometer is ten to the minus eight and
meter square right H is a six point six
10 to the minus 34 jar second okay so
you do that
I have lumber here I have then en for
electron is 0.6 0.6 10 to the minus
twenty-one and square in terms of jar or
in terms of electron volt is the point
is 3 7 10 to the minus 2 and square
electron volt okay
so I said KBT is 26 milli electron volt
so if you look at the electron in this
phenomena theorem the separation between
energy and equals one N equals two
that's a difference is the three times
those lumber that becomes comparable to
KBT right so this shows the quantum if
at become important and but if it's a
air molecule in this space that M now
goes 20 also remember the proton mass is
two thousand times larger right so this
energy separation becomes worse
if it's the air Monaco so for air mark I
don't need to worry about quantum size
effect but for electron and even
strawberry right so this is a where when
we go to nano we could encounter both
quantum and classical size effect and
also as I said that either the interface
if it's idea interface thickness is zero
the way picture always becomes very very
important right and final comment so we
have quantum size in fact classical
sized affect the final comment is a time
right I shoot a laser a very fast later
microsecond later you see can use a
for-real law to describe transform and
when is that become important right this
is the where this cow the time becomes
important and you need to look at your
transport process how does that compare
to this time so mean free parts for air
molecule 100 nanometer velocity 500
right so that's about 10 to the minus 8
second so if you do microsecond don't
worry about it if you do pick out second
or nano second you start worried about
it right so you have time scale you have
length scale and this is where you need
to be able to tell you're safe in one
regime you need to go say you have to
think about that they what kind of size
the effector what kind of effect any
questions
okay if not remember I've like to see
you in my office hour and prefer ever
preferably the first few weeks